hi I'm just like to respond to the sum
of the comics on back here obviously
people I agree with what I'm saying we
had a very good support session this
morning and the general consensus
attribute the values that are installed
coupled with a combined in action from
industry and government could make a
major difference here the values of
sport are really really important and I
think we've established that showing up
almost woke up the impact that the
canary in the life of seminars you know
it's deprived in million YouTube olivium
in the most destitute comedy so very
very much on this on the same team
coming back and saying that end of
consensus someone's the chemosynthesis
an operator so my real point now is ok
nobody sings in the radar why aren't we
all coming together right now sitting
bonusing we collect elbows are doing
right now and if Obama is saying what
the poor money or to public expenditure
as a result of getting us out of this
situation and might be a significant
overlap and you spent one sports coaches
finding building places to play not big
arena small pieces when it can't be very
very creative in the right thing sir in
there as an answer and coming out the
other sorry will be a values-based and
society based on the values for manual a
committed to her family and you said
make imagine